hi there today i want to talk about
some languages are more difficult than
others
um when i said in a recent video that i
found russian to be difficult i think
russian is difficult because of cases
and verbs of motion and aspects of verbs
people say well you shouldn't say that
that discourages people
i do i must say i don't understand that
attitude so you wouldn't study a
language if it was difficult you will
only study a language if it's easy
uh if i think it's difficult i shouldn't
say that i think it's difficult i just
don't understand the mentality there uh
obviously
uh for a speaker of ukrainian russian is
not difficult but for speaker of english
russian is difficult and korean is
difficult i'm finding korean very
difficult
even though i have an advantage over
some people in that i have the chinese
vocabulary
the japanese in a way is a hindrance
because the word order is the same as
korean but but in fact they say things
differently so my brain starts going
down a
japanese pathway instead of a korean
pathway but
however difficult it is that only makes
it more challenging and again as long as
the process is enjoyable it doesn't
really matter if it's difficult i'm very
much looking forward
to uh getting into my uh now we're here
getting into my
uh kim yong-ha
podcast because as i was
running my son's dog through the forest
and i'm going to show you some shots of
our beautiful old-growth forest massive
fur trees and
and uh the waterfall and the whole works
uh listening to kimmel ha not
understanding much so now i want to read
it and i do it on my on our new uh
app
for the ipad which looks like this and
it's much better organized with courses
and lessons and you can even look at it
one sentence at a time rather than the
whole text and many many more features
but unfortunately there's a few
little glitches that have to be fixed
before we uh launch it so i'm not
allowed to talk about it so you didn't
hear that
but it's great and i look forward to
getting back to that as soon as i finish
doing this video
speaking of languages not being
difficult obviously ukrainian and
russian are very similar so it's a lot
of fun for me
oh and i should add russian is difficult
but i've spent enough time at it
and i spent five years at russian korea
and i'm trying to condense it into you
know these three months do as much as i
can with russian i just kind of rolled
with the program did an hour a day but
now i'm in the situation where i can
listen to any interview any discussion i
understand everything they're saying the
odd thing that escapes me if the
you know the line of thinking is a
little obtuse but by and large not a
problem and now i'm listening to the
ukrainian television and getting picking
up more and more of it and what's so
fascinating and what i find so admirable
is that they will interview someone
and the
announcer speaks ukrainian and the
person he's interviewing or she's
interviewing speaks russian and it's
like nothing it's like they just do it
that would never happen at home if it's
a french television station even if they
both speak english it's in french
and if one of them answers in english
it'll be translated but not there it's
just it's like as if it's one language
now
i think the languages are so similar
that people are used to hearing them and
and they understand them but but it's
still admirable and it implies a level
of tolerance of the languages
that kind of seems to contradict a lot
of the
politics a lot of the politicians try to
make things out of language politics
there's no question in my mind that if
ukraine if russian is spoken by half the
population and is the native language of
half or 40 of the population then it
should be an official language and it
should be
the language of instruction at
universities should be available it
should be possible to take one's
university degree and i i think for the
ukraine to hang together they have to
come to some kind of sense of compromise
yes they need to protect the ukrainian
language and build it up as the national
language of the ukraine of ukraine but i
think they have to recognize that people
don't simply want to change their native
language for political reasons
uh so hopefully there's some compromise
there it was interesting watching a
scene in the ukrainian
verhovna rada which is their parliament
where this lady representing the party
of regions which is mostly the eastern
and southern part of ukraine
and she was basically challenging across
the the sort of assembly hall there the
members of the parties faboda and was
basically telling them that they've
they're messing things up because
they're they're feeding the russian
propaganda machine because they tried to
intimidate
this uh television manager in kiev who
aired putin's speech after annexing
after he annexed or russia next uh
crimea
and they told him you know like this was
uh
you know he was a traitor i don't know
what what they were saying and so she
was this little plucky little lady was
saying you know you're damaging her
reputation and she went on to say look
where i come from people are concerned
and the oldest the older generation the
pensioners and so forth they want to be
part of russia because they grew up in
the soviet union that's what they know
and the younger group they want a little
more independence and they want to keep
the russian language and it
seems to me perfectly legitimate
aspirations so she's a ukrainian she
wants to keep the keep ukraine together
and she's telling these civil border
types to back off and then they show
these fabota types that look like
absolute thugs shouting across the hall
and stuff like that now fortunately
svoboda
hopefully has limited influence i think
slovak has more influence in this
interim government than they will have
after elections because all of the polls
show them uh
you know less than five percent than
their leader uh whatever his name is
talking the hook or something is
even less than that so
uh but those are some of the issues that
that ukraine has to uh has to deal with
if it's going to come together as a
country
uh so but yeah so ukraine and and it was
the same when i was listening to my
portuguese podcast from portugal they
would regularly interview spanish people
from spain without any translation
going out to a portuguese-speaking
audience and they could just understand
it so obviously there are some languages
that are not difficult but for an
english speaker both russian and korean
are difficult
and that's all i'm going to say today
bye for now